[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد هذه الليله معكم
في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع واحداث
وتتفاعل اخرى في اليوم العاشر من مونديال
قطر 2022 متابع هذه الصور المباشره من
استاذ احمد بن علي في الريان استعدادا
للشوط الثاني من مباراه انجلترا
من استاد الثمامه في الدوحه حيث تجري
الاستعدادات للشوط الثاني من مباراه اخرى
لا تقل حماسه بين الولايات المتحده وايران
ومن رام الله متابع هذه الصور بعد استشهاد
خمسه فلسطينيين بينهم ضابط في جهاز الامن
الوقائي واصابه اكثر من 20 اخرين من ايران
اقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في الضفه
الغربيه خلال الساعات ال 24 الماضيه
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
مع تكثيف قصف مواقع لفصائل الكرديه في
الشمال السوري انقره تقلل من بواعث القلق
الدولي وتقول ان التدخل برا قد يحدث في اي
وقت واشنطن تتحدث عن تقليس عدد الدورياتها
مع قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه وتؤكد باستمرار
الاتصالات مع الاتراك والازمه على طويله
مجلس الامن وسط تحذيرات دوليه من زعزعه
استقرار المنطقه
عقب اجتماعي وزراء خارجيه حلف الناتو يؤكد
تعزيز قواته شرقي اوروبا بمجموعات قتاليه
صوت البرج يكشف عن امكانيه نقل انظمه
الدفاع الجوي من طراز بيترياط الى
اوكرانيا واشنطن في وجود خطط حاليه لذلك
ومسك تهدد بالرد وباعتبارها هدفا مشروعا
لقوات بلاده
قبل اسبوع من حضر اوروبا وردات الخمر
الروسي خلافات غربيه تعوق محاولاته تحديد
سقف اسعار النفط الروسي وتقارير تقول ان
المحادثات عالقه الصين تعاني من استعدادها
للعمل مع روسيا لدعم امين الطاقه ومسك
تقول ان العقوبات ضدها هي ما سيهدد وضع
الطاقه في العالم
عقبه مظاهرات شهدتها مدن الرئيسيه احتجاج
على اغلاقات بسبب كورونا انتشار كثيف
لقوات الانف العاصمه الصينيه بيجين وفي
شنغهاي والحزب الشيوعي الصيني يدعو الى
قمع ما اعتبرها اعمالا غير قانونيه
وتخريبا تقوم به قوه معاديه
[موسيقى]
في لقائنا اليوم قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا شكوى المدير التنفيذي منصه
تويتر الى مصر مما سماه رسوما مرتفعه من
شركه ابل تلاها الغاء مسؤول رفيع في ابل
حسابه في تويتر كما اضاف ماسك ان ابل
توقفت عن الاعلان عبرته وهددت بحجمها من
متجر التطبيقات فيها متسائلا عما اذا كانت
ابل تكرهه حريه التعبير في امريكا
لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع طرحنا
عليكم السؤال التالي برايكم في اي سياق
ياتي الخلاف الاخير بين تويتر
83% وضعوا الامر في اطار المنافسه
التجاريه بينما ارجعه سبعه عشر في المئه
الى مساله حريه التعبير
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمزي كيو ار الظاهري على الشاشه لقاء
على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا ونتطرق
خلاله لقضايا مستجده
ومتفاعله عربيا ودوليا وبعد الحصاد مباشره
وتحديدا في الساعه الثانيه عشر وخمس دقائق
بتوقيت مكه المكرمه تتابعون الجوله
الرياضيه اليوميه يوميات المونديال التي
ترصد بالخبر والتحليل مباريات كاس العالم
قطر 2002 و 2020
اذا جددت القوات التركيه قصف مواقع ما
تعرف بقوات سوريا ديمقراطيه شمال شرقي
سوريا وقال الناطق باسم الرئاسه التركيه
ابراهيم قال ان العمليه العسكريه التركيه
البريه قد تبدا في اي وقت البنتاجون يقول
انه يواصل الاتصالات مع الاتراك ويقلص عدد
الدوريات مع قوات سوريا ديمقراطيه وانا
تركيزه ينصب على القضاء على تنظيم الدوله
تبذل اخر الجهود للتوصل الى تسويه تغني عن
عمليه بريه تركيه جديده ضد ما يعرف بقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه تجدد تركيا تهديدها
ومطالبها وتشير الى ان العمليه البريه في
الشمال السوري يمكن ان تبدا في اي وقت
تكشف وسائل الاعلام المقربه من النظام
السوري على لقاء في شمال سوريا جمع قائد
القوات الروسيه في سوريا اليكساندر شايكو
بالقائد فيما يعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه مصدومه عبدي وتتحدث عن تقديم
شيكو عرضا بان تحل قوات النظام السوري محل
القوات الكرديه لا يعرف ما هو موقف ما
يسمى بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه من العرض
الروسي كما لم تعلن واشنطن التي تعد
الحديث الرئيسيه لما يسمى بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه حتى الان موقفها من المطالب
بالتركيه قال جون كيربي منسقه الاتصالات
في مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي ان من حق
تركيا
والارهاب عن نفسها لكنه اوضح في الوقت
نفسه ان واشنطن ليست مع اي اعمال قد تؤدي
الى وقوع ضحايا او تدر بجهودها لمواصله
العمل مع شركائها السوريين ضد تنظيم
الدوله الشركاء السوريون الذين يتحدث عنهم
كربي هم مقاتلوا ما يعرف بوحداث حمايه
الشعب الكرديه الذين تعتبرهم تركيا حليفه
الامريكيين في النيتو ارهابيين في اجتماع
وزراء خارجيه النيت ببخار سيكون موضوع
الوضع في شمال سوريا حاضرا بابعاده
المختلفه ستناقش الحمله البريه التركيه
المحتمله والدعم الذي تقول تركيا انك لندى
والسويد الراغبتين في الانضمام تقدمانه
لحزب العمال الكردستاني والذي بسبب به لم
توافق على انضمامهما بعد قال وزير
الخارجيه مولود شوشو اوغلو ان تقدم من
تحقق بشان الدعم الذي تقدمه السويد لندن
لحزب العمال الكردستاني مشيرا الى ضروره
اتخاذ اضافيه خصوصا من طرف السويد تطورات
كانت حاضره في مجلس الامن الدولي حيث حضر
المبعوث الاموي الخاص الى سوريا من وجود
عناصر تصعيد خطير في شمال سوريا يمكن اي
يهدد الاستقرار الاقليمي
وفي تعليقه على التطورات عرب المبعوث
الاممي الخاص الى سوريا جير بدرسن عن قلقه
البالغ اذا تصعد العنفي في شمال سوريا
وحذر من ان تصاعد القتال قد يعرض
الاستقرار الاقليمي للخطر
يسمحوا لي ان احذر مجلس الامن من
السيناريو الذي تكون فيه للعمليات
العسكريه وسعه النطاق اثار غير مباشره في
جميع المناطق الاخرى مما يؤدي الى انهاء
الهدوء النسبي الذي دام ما يقرب من ثلاثه
اعوام لن يؤدي مثل هذا التصعيد الى تفاقم
الضرر المدمر الذي لحق بالمدنيين السوريين
فحسب بل سيعرض ايضا الاستقرار الاقليميه
للخطر الجماعه الارهابيه التي تم اخذاها
ولكن لم تهزم ستستغل حاله عدم الاستقرار
من جانبها قالت المندوبه الامريكيه في
مجلس الامن الدولي لندن فيلد ان واشنطن
تشعر بقلق ايذاء الاعمال العسكريه الاخيره
وتاثيرها على استقرار المنطقه
في سوريا يتعين على جميع الاطراف الموافقه
على تنفيذ وقف اطلاق نار شامل على مستوى
البلاد يحمي المدنيين من العنف تحث
الولايات المتحده على وقت فوري للتصعيد في
شمال سوريا نحن قلقون للغايه من الاعمال
العسكريه الاخيره التي استقرار المنطقه
وتهدد هدفنا المشترك لمحاربه داعش وتعرض
المدنيين والافراد الامريكيين للخطر
رغم تاكيد المسؤولين على الاتراك على
ضروره ضمان امني حدود بلادهم الجنوبيه فان
العمليه العسكريه البريه التركيه المحتمله
قد تؤجل او تحقق اهدافها دون ان تبدا حتى
كيف ذلك وما هي سيناريوهات بدء العمليه
العسكريه التركيه من عدمه ونطاقها
الجغرافي نتعرف عليها في العرض التاليه
الديمقراطيه شمال الشرقيه سوريا واحتمال
شنه عمليه عسكريه تفتح تركيا الباب امام
حلول توقف معها عمليتها العسكريه البريه
المحتمله المتحدث باسم الرئاسه التركيه
ابراهيم قالن او ضحاسه بان ينسحب المسلحون
الاكراد الى عمق 30 كلم بعيدا عن الحدود
مع تركيا مصادر رسميه تركيه قالت للجزيره
ان الجانب الروسي هو من يسعى لتهدئه
الاوضاع وانما تطلبه انقره والسحابه ما
تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه من منبج
وعين العرب ثم يملا الفراغ في تلك المناطق
مؤسسات النظام السوري الامنيه وحرس الحدود
من المسلحين الاكراد
قائد ما تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
ابدم خوفا من بدي هجوم بريان تركيه رغم ما
وصفها بتطميات واشنطن ومرد ذلك ما قال انه
استمرار تركيا في حشد مزيد من قواتها عند
الحدود في الوقت نفسه فان المسؤولين
الاتراك شددوا على ان جيش بلادهم سينفذ
هجوما بريا يحقق فيه امن الحدود الجنوبيه
لتركيا وذلك في حال عدم تنفيذ المسلحين
الاكراد لشروط انقره تجدر الاشاره اخيرا
الى ان معطيات شمال الشرقيه
تشابهما حدث عام 2019 من الاتفاق الروسيين
تركيين في سوتشي تضمن وقتها بلدا انسحاب
المسلحين الاكراد وابتعادهم عن الحدود
وحلول قوات النظام السوري مكانهم وهو ما
لم ينفذ وفق المسؤولين الاتراك مع فارق
واحد هو ان اتفاق سوتشي جاء بعد عمليه
عسكريه بريه تركيه
[موسيقى]
المزيد حول هذا الموضوع معنا من اسطنبول
محمد تشيليك الكاتب الصحفي ومن موسكو
اليكسي يخلفني كوف الخبير في شؤون الشرق
الاوسط بالمجلس الروسي للشؤون الخارجيه
مرحبا بكما الكسيغلبني كوف ما هي
المقترحات الروسيه لحل الازمه
امامنا في شمال سوريا هي ليست بالجديده
القضيه كانت موجوده عام 2019 كما تعرفون
كان هنالك اتفاق تم التوصل اليه حيث
بموجبه
سيكون هناك القوات الفصائل الكرديه ابتعد
في منطقه العازله لعمق 30 كلمه القوات
الكرديه والفصائل ما تزال موجوده مؤخرا
سمعنا ان الحكومه التركيه قد اعلنت
شروطها من اجل
العمليه ان لا يتم اطلاقها وكانت شروط
تتمثل من سحاب كل القوات الكرديه من عين
العرب
بالتالي فان احدى اتفاقيات المحتمله هنا
هو ان اذا قامت القوات السوريه
له المحل ال- ال- القصائد الكرديه في تلك
المناطق لكن علينا ان لا ننسى ايضا بنسبه
لروسيا فان الاتفاق مع تركيا حول شمال
سوريا ياتي ايضا في همم
ارتباطا وثيق بموقفي والوضع في ادلب لانه
خلال الاتفاق الذي عقدته تركيا مع روسيا
والولايات المتحده كان هناك ضرورا لفصل
القوات المعتدله في ادلب عن الفصائل
والمجموعات المتطرفه والارهابيه مثل جبهه
التحرير الشام هذا الشرط وهذا الاتفاق لم
يتم تطبيق ايضا بالتالي لا يجب ان ننسى
هذا هذه الجزئيه ايضا ان القضيه يعني
مرتبطه ثاني ببعضها نعملوا انه خلال
الايام القادمه او الاسابيع القادمه لربما
قد يكون ذلك نوع من التسويه محمد
همم تقبل تركيا بهذا المقترح ابعاد لما
يعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه 30 كم احلال
قوات النظام وحرس الحدود مكانها
كما تعرفون كان هنالك في عام 2019 كما قال
المتحدث من ناموسكو كان هنالك اتفاق لكن
لم يتم تنفيذه لذلك تركيا تحاول الان ان
تصل الى نوع من السلام المستدامه للحرب
هناك وتركيا تريد ايضا ان تضمن حدودها من
ارهابي وحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه وان
يكون هنالك منطقه عازله لمسافه 30 كلم في
منبج وعين العرب
سيكون هناك استبدال لقوات الكرديه بقوات
سوريا حكوميه يجب ان يكون هنالك عنصر
الثقه وقضيه اخرى تم تتم مناقشاتها
بالنسبه لقوات المعارضه
المعتدله التي دعمتها تركيا وفرت لها قوه
ملادات امنه هناك هذه قضيه ايضا واسئله يج
الاجابه عليها اذا ما تم التواصل الى نوع
من الاتفاق همم عن طريق اجتماع مع النظام
النظام قد طلب نوع من التسويه والتنازلات
من تركيا لكن اعتقد انه يجب ان يقرر حول
ملء سيكون رد فعلها عندما
من اجل سلاح حمايتي اراضيه بوجود قوات
حمايه الشعب الكرديه محمد سيد محمد هل هل
تركيا مستعده لتقديم ما يتعين تقديمه من
قبلها في ادلب كما ذكر ضيفنا من موسكو
لقاء حصولها علامات تريد في شرق الفرات
وانا تركيه ليست مستعد لاعطاء ما يطلبه
النظام لكن تركيا مستعده لاعطاء مابي
وسعها من اجل تامين مصالحها الوطنيه وهذا
ما قاله الرئيس اردوغان ليس هنالك مصالح
وطنيه وقال انه عندما يتعلق بالمحادثات مع
النظام السوري فيما يتعلق بادلب علينا ان
نؤكد على قضيه ان النظام وايضا موسكو لما
عندما يتعلق بقصف المناطق المدنيه هناك
بالتالي
كان هنالك اتفاق لكنه لم يحقق تطبيقه
هل تتوقع روسيا اساسا ان تقبل ما يعرف
بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه بهذه المقترحات
حتى تمضي المساله قدوما باتجاه تسوى
السياسيه
كويس كويس
لروسيا ان لا يكون هناك تصعيد في الوضع لا
تقوم تركيا باطلاق عمليه بريه واسعه
بالتالي لان هذا الامر سيعقد الكثير ليس
فقط على الكورد ولكن على الامريكيين
والرؤوس والروس لكن ايضا على تركيا نفسها
بالتالي هذه
شو رايك
ان تقنع تركيا في ان تبحث عن بدائل
وقد شاهدنا خلال السته اشهر الماضيه هذا
الامر كان هنالك
خطط تركيه لاطلاقيه عمليه تم اعلان عنها
في شهر منذ شهر مايو ولحد الان لم نرى
عمليه بريه الموسعه
اذا ما كنا نتحدث عن ايجاد نوع من التسويه
او تنازلات من الاطراف فان السيناري
المحتمله وعقد تكون عمليه محدوده اذا لم
يتم تطبيق شروط ومعينه من تركيا لكن في
نهايه الوضع المثالي هو ان يكون هنالك
شروط تركيا انسحاب الفصائل الكرديه من هذه
المناطق الثلاثه
المجلس الروسي للشؤون الخارجيه وشكرا
لمحمد شالك الكاتب الصحفي من اسطنبول
[موسيقى]
حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا وتداعياتها تصدرت
اجتماعا وزراء الخارجيه الدول الاعضاء
شمال الاطلسي تستضيفه رومانيا في ختام
اليوم اليوم الاول للاجتماعات الوزاريه
اكد نيته تعزيز قواته شرقي اوروبا بمجموعه
قتاليه وكشف الامين العام الحلف عن
امكانياته نقل انظمه الدفاع الجوي الى
اوكرانيا
وباعتبار الانظمه هدفا مشروعا للقوات
الروسيه
يوم ذكيه في بوخارست في اجتماعات العاصمه
الرومانيه مساحه الارض تماسك حلف الناتو
ووحده موقفه تجاه الحرب في اوكرانيا
لحشد مزيد من الدعم للاوكرانيين في
المجتمعون يرون ان ملايين منهم محرومون من
الخدمه الانسانيه الاساسيه بفعل الهجمات
الروسيه المستمره على البنيه التحتيه
المدنيه وتلك الخاصه بالطاقه في اوكرانيا
سريعا تحول الانشغال الى تعهد جديد اجتماع
وزاره الخارجيه دولي الحلف بشر اوكرانيا
بمواصله دعمها والمساعده في اصلاح بنيتها
التحتيه للطاقه بينما تواصل بحسب بيان
نيته الدفاع عن سيادتها وسلامته اراضيها
يترافق اذن الالتزام باصلاح منشات الطاقه
في اوكرانيا مع التزام الاخره بحمايه
شعبها من الهجمات الصاروخيه الروسيه
قد لا يرى الحلف في انتساب كيف الى منظمه
الدفاع الاطلسيه الاولويه في الوقت الراهن
غير انه بدا مستعدا للذهاب ابعد في دعم
قواتها في مواجهه روسيا لانه يبحث مثلا
امكانيه نقل انظمه الدفاع الجوي من طرازي
باتريوس الى اوكرانيا
جديده الى اوكرانيا مثل منظومه وهناك
محادثات جاريه الان بشان هذه المنظومه لكن
من ناحيه اخرى يجب التاكد من ان ما سيتم
تسليمه يعمل بكثافه عاليه ولهذه الغايه
نريد التاكد من توفير قطاع الغيار اللازمه
من اجل عمليه الصيانه والذخيره
تشعر موسكو بان الامر يستهدفها نائب رئيس
مجلس الامن الروسي
قال انه في حال زود النيته اوكرانيا
بانظمه باتريوت فستصبح تلك الانظمه هدفا
مشروعا للقوات الروسيه
في اوكرانيا مازال يحتل اهميته بنسبه لها
وتؤكد تصميما على مواجهه ما تصفها
باعتداءات بوتين في اوكرانيا لكن
الامريكيين يحرصون مع ذلك على بيان الا
خطط لديهم الان لارسال بطاريتهم الشهيره
الى اوكرانيا
بالقدر الكافي فهم يتهمون الولايات
المتحده بتبني نهج يصفون
والمعاد لهم
هناك ما تقول موسكو انه جعل الحوار معها
بخصوص اوكرانيا غير ممكن لاختلاف الرؤى
بشكل جذري وهو عينه ما دفعها كما تقول
لتاجيل المحادثات المقرره مع المسؤولين
الامريكيين هذا الاسبوع بشان معاهده ستارت
للحد من انتشار الاسلحه النوويه
بجامعه
الحسين موضوع
الولايات المتحده بانه لم يتم تقديمها في
هذه المرحله لاوكرانيا باعتقادك رغم
تصريحات الصوت
هنالك الكثير من
تحفظ من جانب الولايات المتحده لان
الولايات المتحده اصبحت منخرطه بشكل كبير
في هذه الحرب لذلك اعتقد ان هنالك الحرب
المباشره بين الولايات المتحده وروسيا
ودعم اوكرانيا هذا الضوء هذا الخلطه
والفاصل بدا يضيق بالتالي هنالك المزيد من
الاختلافات الان في داخل النيته حول الى
اي مدار يريدون ان ياخذوا هذه الحرب
الوكاله ضد روسيا ما تضيعت هذا الاختلافات
منكم
الاساسيه داخل نقطه الخلافه الاساسيه داخل
النيته هي ان الكثير من الاسلحه والمخازن
الاسلحه في الغرب قد تمت قد نفذت وهذا
الامر يخلقون العديد من الكثير من الضغط
لارسال الكثير من الاسلحه الثقيله لان
اوكرانيا
خسائر كبيره والغرب لا يمكن ان يعوضوا هذه
الخسائر بالتالي ما لم يقم بنيته بتوفير
المزيد من الاسلحه فان اوكرانيا همم تلحق
بها الهزيمه لكن اذا كانت تجهيزات النيته
اكثر فعاليه قد يكون هنالك انخراط مع حرب
مباشره مع روسيا لذلك السبب هنالك مصالح
مختلفه وخلافه داخل النيته الولايات
المتحده تريد ان تقضي على اكثر عدد من
الروس لكنها لا تريد ان تنخرطها بشكل
مباشر مع الحرب لكن الدول الاخرى تريد ان
انخراطا قليلا لكن دول اخرى قد تريد ان
تنخرط بشكل اكبر هناك تحدي اخر الان امام
النيتو الوضع الانساني في اوكرانيا في ضوء
الاتهامات بروسيا بانها تقوم بشكل متعمد
باستهداف البنا التحتيه المدنيه والكهرباء
وانه يجري استخدام فصل الشتاء كسلاح ضد
الاوكرانيين ماذا عن هذا الجانب كيف
باعتقادك سيتم التعامل معه
لا يستطيع الغرب القيام بالكثير لكن ايضا
هنالك موقف فيه الكثير من النفاق لانه
عندما قام النايته بغزوه غسلافيه في عام
1999 قاموا بتدميره 80% من انظمه الطاقه
في غسلافيه وعندما قام الامريكيين بغزو
العراق ايضا قاموا بتدمير انظمه الكهرباء
ومشيئه الكهرباء هذه الطريقه معتاده لشن
الحرب والخوض الحرب لان الجيوش تستخدم نفس
الانظمه من اجل ان تتحرك قواتها بالتالي
الامر لا يتعلق بالمنشات المدنيه لكنها
اداها تستخدمها نعرف ان النيته الامريكي
يقومون ب همم قصف هذه المنشات الكهرباء
عندما يقومون به بشكل اولي قول ذلك لكننا
لا اعرف تماما ما الذي سنوي بهذا منخرط في
حرب نشره مع روسيا ربما سيكون ذلك لا
تجهيز لانظمه دفاع جويه لكن لا يعتقد في
حقيقه الامر ان هذا الامر سيساعد همم
الوضع لان الروس يقومون باطلاق المزيد من
الصواريخ
استاذ العلاقات الدوليه بجامعه الخبير في
شؤون اوراسيا ضيفنا من اوسلو
لاحقا في حصاد هذه الليله سنتوقف عند
مساعدات غربيه محتمله لاوكرانيا ونسال
ضيفا عن احتمالات تاثيرها على مجرى الحرب
[موسيقى]
نقلت وكاله بلومبرج عن دبلوماسيين
اوروبيين قولهم ان المحادثات بشان تحديد
سقف اعلى لاسعار النفط الروسي لا تزال
عالقه في ظل الاستمرار الجدل بين الاطراف
الاوروبيه فبينما تدفع دول الى رفع سقف
السعر خشيه ان يلحق الضرر ان يلحق الضرر
الاقتصادياتها تدفع بولندا ودول البلطيق
باتجاه المعاكس على امل ان يؤدي ذلك الى
ضغط اكبر على الاقتصاد الروسي
تمثل جهود الاتحاد الاوروبي ومن قبله
مجموعه الدول الصناعيه السبع الكبرى في
وضع سقف سعر اعلى للنفط الروسي محاوله
اخرى للضغط المالي على موسكو التي يمثل
لها تصدير النفط الخام واحدا من اهم مصادر
تمويل خزينه الدوله وبالتالي تمويل الحرب
على اوكرانيا فما الذي تعنيه بالضبط هذه
الخطوه التزام الدول المستهلكه للنفط
الروسي بعدم تجاوز السقف الاعلى لسعر
برميل النفط في عقود الشراء المبرمه مع
موسكو دون النظر الى السعر الحالي الذي
يباع فيه النفط في الاسواق العالميه ففي
حال اعتمد السقف عند 60 دولارا ووصل سعر
برميل النفط عالميا الى 120 دولارا فان
عقود الشراء بين موسكو والمستهلكين لنفقها
يجب ان لا تزيد على ذلك
وما سيدفع اكثر منه ولو بسنت واحد فسيجد
نفسه في مرمى العقوبات الغربيه
لكن استمرار الجدل داخل البيت الاوروبي
بشان السقف الذي يجب ان تعتمده لسعر النفط
الروسي لا يزال يعطل حتى الان الوصول الى
اتفاق يرضي كل الاطراف استدفع دول مثل
قبرص واليونان ومالطا باتجاه رفع السقف
لاعلى قدر ممكن لاعتماد جزء من اقتصادها
على الشحن البحري في حين تضغط دول مثل
بولندا و ليتوانيا واسبانيا لخفض السقف
فالحديث عن سعرا يراويح بين 65 دولارا
للبرميل كما اقترحت الدول السبع الكبرى او
62 دولارا كما مقترح داخل المناقشات
الاوروبيه لن يضر موسكو برايها ولا يمكن
ان يشكل اي ضغط عليها لان الخامه الروسي
يتداول حاليا بحدود ثلاثه و60$
[موسيقى]
وبولندا بان يكون السقف الاعلى لبرميل
النفط الروسي نحو ثلاثين دولارا فقط وهي
خطوه تخشى اطراف غربيه ان تدفع روسيا الى
حظر تصدير نفطها الخام ما قد يؤدي الى
ازمه في سوق الطاقه واشتعال اسعار النفط
اضافه الى ان اكبر مستهلكين للنفذ الروسي
هما الصين والهند ولا يتوقع ان يتجاوبان
مع اي خطوه غربيه لفرد سقف اعلى سعره لكنه
ورقه الضغط الاهم للدول الغربيه هي في
ملكيتها لقرابه 90% من شركات التامين
الخاصه بالملاحه البحريه في العالم وفي
حال حضره التعامل مع شحنات الخمرسي ما لم
يتم بيعها باقل من السعر الذي حدثت سقفه
فانه سيصعب جدا على موسكو بيعه نفقها بسعر
اعلى من ذلك السقف
قال الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ان
العلاقات بين روسيا والصين مستمره في
التطور رغم عدم الاستقرار الدولي وقال
بوتن في رساله للمشاركين في منتدى اعمال
طاقه الروسيه الصينيه الرابعه ان الطاقه
تبقى احد المجالات الرئيسيه والاكثر
ديناميكيه في تعاون البلدين الاقتصادي من
ناحيته اكد الرئيس الصيني سجن في رسالته
للمنتدى النصين مستعده للعمل مع روسيا من
اجل دعم ام النطاق في العالم
من برلين معنى توماس او دونال الخبير في
شؤون الاقتصادي والطاقه والاستاذ بمدرسه
هيرتي العليا ببرلين مرحبا بك سيد تو
مسعود ما دلالات استمرار الخلاف بين الدول
الاوروبيه على وضع سقف بسعر النفط الروسي
رغم الحديث عن هذا الامر منذ اسابيع
والحديث عن وحده اوروبيه في مواجهه روسيا
من اجل ان تتم معاقبتها ودعم اوكرانيا
جريني شكرا على الاستضافه انا لست
متفاجئه بشكل كبير انه هنالك صعوبه
يواجهونها الاوروبيون في حقيقه الامر ليس
هنالك يجب ان لا يكون هنالك روسيا
والفوتان النقاشات انها تريد بعض الدول
تريد ان تصاحب الامور على روسيا بولندا
استونيا ودول اخرى التي قدموها الدول
الخطوط الاماميه هي تريد ان تزيد من الضغط
هي تريد بالتالي اسعار اقل او سعرا اقل
انا متاكد ان
الوزراء في المنتدى الطاقه
قريبا قد يكون هنالك 65
ربما ربما بشكل اعلى بكثير او اقل بكثير
كيف سيحسم الخلاف باعتقادك
بتسجيل
الاتحاد الاوروبي لدينا 27 دوله كل دوله
يجب ان يسمح لها باعطاء رايها هذا الامر
سيكون وضعا صعبا للغايه على روسيا
كان هنالك
بشكل تجريجي ستكون هذا الامر نهايه السوق
في الاتحاد الاوروبي مادام فوت الموجود في
السلط هذا السقف على السعر الفكره تتمثل
بان يكون هنالك ساقف سيبقى
دفتر روسيه في سوق لكن باسعار منخفضه وقد
يتم استمرار ببيعه في الهند وتركيا والصين
وهي الدول الثلاثه الرئيسيه التي تقوم
بشهر لكن هذا الامر بشكل تدريجي وبمرور
الوقت مثلا دول الاخرى مثل فنزويلا وليبيا
او التي ستقوم بانتاج المزيد من النفط
خلال سنوات القادمه ستنخفض الاسعار
وبالتالي ستضغط على بشكل المتزوج
الامريكيين لا يريدون ان يخلقوا صدمه وان
يبعدوا النفط الروسيه عن السوق بشكل
المفاجئ شكرا لك الخبير
والاستاذ مدرسه هورتي العليا ببرلين ضيفنا
من برلين
[موسيقى]
تتسارع التطورات في الصين في اعقاب
احتجاجات عامه مدنا عده على القيود التي
تفرضها السلطات لكبح تفشي فيروس كرونه
الحزب الشيوعي الصيني دعا الى قمع ما سمه
الاعمال الاجراميه وغير القانونيه التي
تخل بالنظام العام
وحدها الصين بقيت على عهد ازمنه الاغلاق
وقيود الحركه لمنع مزيد من انتشار فيروس
كورونا
الان وقد عمه الاحتجاجات على ذلك كبرى
مدنها دعا الحزب الشيوعي الحاكم الى
التعامل بحزم مع دعوات الاحتجاج في اجتماع
لجنته السياسيه والقانونيه المركزيه شدد
الحزب على ضروره قمع ما وصفها بعمليات
التسلل والتخريب التي تقوم بها قوات
معاديه دعا ايضا الى قمع الاعمال غير
القانونيه والاجراميه التي تخل بالنظام
الاجتماعي وفق بيان الحزب
يشهد شارع الصيني بوادر بدء تنفيذ هذه
التوصيات فقد انتشر افراد الامن في مدينتي
بيجين وشنكاي لمنع عوده الاحتجاجات على
الاجراءات الحكوميه الصارمه لاحتواء فيروس
كورونا
يمنع هنا شرطي تصوير فحصه لهواتف احد
الماره حيث توقف الشرطه الصينيه بعضهم
للتحري بحثا عن اي محتوى او برامج مشبوهه
بما في ذلك الشبكات الافتراضيه الخاصه
التي يمكن استخدامها لتجاوز الرقابه على
الانترنت
للصين اقيمتها على طول هذا التاريخ الذي
شهد في عطله نهايه الاسبوع تجمع عن حاسدا
لرافدي سياسات الاغلاق وصف بالاضخم منذ
عقود لا تريد السلطات مشاهد مماثله في
الايام المقبله وهنا في الحرم الرئيسي
لجامعه هونج كونج وبوجوههم بالكاد تظهر
ملامحها يحتاج الطلاب على تمسك الحكومه
بالقيود الاحترازيه
ذهب بعضهم الى درجه مطالبه الرئيس في جيم
بينج بلصقاله بالنسبه لبيجين لا مرد لهذه
القيود لانها تسند حسب الحكومه الصينيه
الى معطيات علميه دقيقه
اثبتت الحقائق ان اجراءات الصين بشان
فيروس كورونا تستند الى العلم وانها صحيحه
وفعاله سنواصل تنفيذ الاجراءات المستنده
الى العلم والدقه حيث نضمن الاحتواء
الفعال ونسعل دفع التنميه الاجتماعيه
والاقتصاديه تصر سلطات الصينيه على
الاستمرار في تطبيق
وهي سياسه تلزم الحكومات المحليه بفرض
اغلاقات عامه
واصدار اوامر بالحجر الصحي والحد من حريه
التنقل لكبح تفشل انتشار فيروس كورونا
وثارت الاحتجاجات بشانها بعد مصر 10 اشخاص
بسبب حريق شباب
يعتقد المتظاهرون ان قيود الاغلاق اعاقه
عمل فرق
حول هذا الموضوع معنا من بيجين الرونج هو
وان الاعلامي والبحث السياسي ومن واشنطن
معنا الدكتور ريتشارد وايد رئيس قسم
دراسات الصين بمعهديه عطسه مرحبا بكمارو 1
هل باللجوء الى هذه الحلول الامنيه التي
لجات اليها السلطات في الصين
يحسم موضوع هذه الاحتجاجات ضد سياسه صفر
كوفد
الاجراءات الامنيه كلها للحفاظ على
الاستقرار الاجتماع
الاجتماعي
الصينيه لمن شارك في هذه الاحتجاجات هناك
محاولات لي قمع كل الاحتجاج يخرج هناك
حديث من الهيئات الامنيه الصينيه عن قمه
ان يستهدف ما تسميه قوات معاديه في الصين
يعني تتعامل مع هذه التظاهرات وكانها قوات
عادي
طبعا يعني هناك
بعد القوه يعني الذين يعني احداث السيئه
السياسيه الخفيه وذلك هذه الاجراءات من 20
معهم
ولكن الانتقادات يعني ممكن ولكن الاعمال
شغب مرفوض تماما فهذا هو الموقف همم
الحكومات في هذا شيء فهنا هناك دعم لحمايه
الحبوب وكذلك
عايز ما رايك يعني هناك معارضه لاعمال
الشغب ولكن حقوق الجميع محفوظه في
الانتقاد والمعارضه
لا اعتقد ان هذا يعكس واقع ما حدث اعتقد
ان الاحتجاجات تم السماح بها عندما يتم
يكون الانتقاد موجها الى مسؤولينا محليين
او ربما اشخاص
ليسوا من الساسه من المشاهير مثلا لكن
عندما يتعلق الامر بدعواته
لاستبدال قادتي همم قاده في الحزب الله
الشيوعيه او انهاء سيطرت واحتكار الحزب
الشريعي فسيتم قمع هذه الاحتجاجات سواء
كانت عنيف ام لا انا لم ارى اي دواء دليل
على انخراف قوه خارجيه رايت فقط اشخاصا
همم يشعرون بعادهم الرضاعه اتجاهها
السياسات حكوميه معينه ويريدون ان يوضحوها
يوضح هذا الامر عن طريق الاحتجاج
همم كيف نفهم هذا التمسك من جانب السلطات
الصينيه
بتطبيق سياسه صفر كوفيد مع كل ما يترافق
معها من اجراءات يرى الكثير من الصينيين
عنها اصبحت قمعيه في وقت تخلى معظم العالم
معظم دول العالم تخلت عن هكذا اجراءات
عدده بسبب هذه الاجراءات نجحت 90 في تقليل
عدد همم وفيات بسبب بكرونا في سن الى اقل
يعني الى مستوى منخفضه جدا مقارنه مع
الدول الاخرى هناك في مثلا في الولايات
المتحده هناك اكثر من مليون شخص توفي بسبب
قرون
مقارنه مع ذلك
واذا تم ازاله الجميع والاجراءات فيتم همم
يعني الصين لا تريد ان تتكرر هذا همم يعني
مشهد في الصين
وهناك دراسه علميه بان اذا تم ازاله هذا
هذه الاجراءات فيتم همم
يكون عدده الوفيات بسبب
يتجاوز مليون و600 الف شخص
وكذلك لان الصين فيها الكثافه السكانيه
كبيره اعلى في العالم وكذلك اعداد المسنين
ايضا كبير جدا ولذلك
الحكومه التي تعمل على همم
وضع الحياه المواطنين في مقام الاول وتمسك
بالسياسه همم
كذلك هناك الدعوات ايضا من بعض المواطنين
ايضا اللي تماسك بها لانهم يخافون التعارف
همم يعني حياته ليه الخدر
نعم في حقيقه الامر انا لست لا حول ولا
انتقد سياسه الصين
اعتقد ان من الجيد جدا يتم فحص الجميع وان
يكون هناك اعتقد انه هنالك الكثير من
الاماكن في واشنط قد تخلت عن هذه
الاجراءات بشكل متسرع الشيء الوحيد الذي
اراه ربما مساله
الاغلاق التي اراها مشدده وقد لا تكون يتم
ادارتها بشكل فعال بحيث
تمنع الناس من الحصول على الاحتياجات
الضروريه اعتقد ان اجراءات الاغلاق يجب ان
يتم ادارتها بشكل افضل لكن مساله ارتداء
الكمامات وان يكون هنالك ربما
تقنيه
والاجراءات المترافقه معها يعني هذه
الاحتجاجات اصلا
انطلقت من جراء وقوع حريق ادى الى وقوع
قتلى لم يتم التعامل معه بالشكل المطلوب
بسبب هذه الاجراءات وبالتالي هناك تملم
الكبير وقد يفضي ذلك يعني سمح الى خروج
تظاهرات لا تخرج عاده في الصين وبالتالي
ما حجم وتاثير ما حدث باختصار شديد
نعم نعم انا اوافق الراي بعض اجراءات
الاغلاق قد تكون
ربما مبالغ فيها هنالك قد يكون بعض الرضا
من بعض الناس في الصين وقد يكون انا اللي
كان مخاوف من لدى بعض الاخر اعتقد انهم ان
يبدوا ان الحكومه قد حاولت ان همم تسيطر
وتحتوي الاحتجاجات عن طريق اجراءات شديده
عن طريق همم شكرا لكم
رئيس قسم دراسات الصين بمعهد حسن من
واشنطن وشكرا لرونانج الاعلامي والبحث
السياسي
[موسيقى]
استشهد خمسه فلسطينيين بينهم ضابط في جهاز
الامن الوقائي الفلسطيني واصيب اكثر من 20
اخرين قوه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في رام
الله والخليل بالضفه الغربيه خلال الساعات
ال 24 الماضيه وشيع الفلسطينيون في بلدتي
بيت ريما وبيت امر جسمينا ثلاثه شهداء
بينهم الشقيقان ظافر وجواد الرماوي
[موسيقى]
لحظات عصيبه عاشها والداء الشهيدين
الشقيقين ظافر وجواد الريماوي بعد ان
خطفهما رصاص الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من بين
احضانهما
[تصفيق]
غضب وحزن في رام الله والخليل الشهيدان
ظافر وجواده استشهد خلال مواجهات وقعت في
قريه كفرعين المجاوره بقريتهما بيت ريما
شماليه رام الله
وفي بلده بيت امر في الخليل شيع الشهيد
الشاب مفيد الذي اصيب برصاص الاحتلال
بينما كان يوثق عمليه اقتحام اسرائيلي
للبلده
اصابه قوات الاحتلال الشاب جواد باصابه في
ايقاتله في جسمه واراد شقيقه الاخر الذي
كان بجانبه ان ينقله
بالصراخ واراد ان ينقذه بسيئه الاسعاف
يعني السكان المجاورين سمع- سمعوا صراخ
وهو ينادي اسعاف واراد ان ينقذه الطلبه من
منه لكي ينقذه ولكن قوه الاحتلال لم تعطيه
المجال
ياتي هذا التصعيد الاسرائيلي منظرا
بالمزيد من التدخل الامني مع اركان حكومه
الاسرائيليه يراها فلسطينيون على انها
اكثر وتطرفا
يبدو ان الحكومه الاسرائيليه تخطط لتصعيد
كما يبدو تصعيد في القوانين تصعيد في
الاجراءات وتصعيد في الفعل على الارض هذا
الوضع ربما يستلزم فلسطينيا الذهاب اكثر
واكثر الى معاقبه اسرائيل لمعاقبه اسرائيل
في همم المحاكم الدوليه
جامعه بيرزيت اعلنت الحداده على ارواح
الشهداء خصوصا شهيديها الريماوي وسط حاله
واسعه من التمديد بين جمهورها كما حملت
الرئاسه الفلسطينيه وحقتها الى جانب
الفصائل الوطنيه والاسلاميه الاحتلال
المسؤوليه عند داعيت هذا التصعيد
باستشهاد اربعه شبان اخرين ارتفع عدد
الشهداء الفلسطينيه في الضفه الغربيه
وقطاع غزه منذ بدايه هذا العام الى 206
وهو ما يعتبره الفلسطينيون العام الاكثر
دمويه مقرره بالعامين الماضيين مشاعر
الحزن والغضب شعبيه وسياسيا في هذا اليوم
العالمي للتضامن مع الشعب الفلسطيني
ترافقت مع المطالبه بتدخل دولي عاجل
لمحاسبه الجنى
سمير ابو شماله الجزيره رام الله فلسطين
والشاعر عبد العزيز المقالح الى مثواه
الاخير في مقبره خزيمه بصنعاء وكانت
المنيه قد وافق الشاعر عن عمر نهز ال 85
بعد رحله حافله في عده مجالات علميه
وثقافيه كما تقلد المقالح العديده من
المناصب كرئيس جامعه صنعاء ورئيس مركز
البحوث ودراسات حتى وفاته وقد حصل الراحل
على عدد من الجوائز العالميه منها جائزه
الثقافه العربيه من اليونسكو بباريس عام
2002 وسام الفارس الذي قلدته اياها
الحكومه الفرنسيه عام 2003
[موسيقى]
بالعوده الى شان الاوكراني مع استمرار
المعارك واقرار كيف بصعوبات على الجبهه
نصلي الضوء على مساعده عسكريه محتمله
لاوكرانيا من دول الغرب وتحديدا الولايات
المتحده تنقل رويترز عن مصادر مطلعه ان
البنتاجون يدرس اقتراحا لتزويد اوكرانيا
بقنا بلا دقيقه صغيره يجري تثبيتها على
صواريخ والقنابل وذات والقطر الصغير التي
تطلق من الارض موجهه بنظام تحديد المواقع
العالمي جي بي اس ويمكنها التغلب على بعض
انواع التشويش الالكترونيه كما يمكن
استخدامها في جميع ظروف الطقس رغم ان
الولايات المتحده رفضت طلبات لتوفير
صواريخ يناهز مداها 300 كلم فانا مدى
القنابل محل البحث يبلغ 150 كلم
تجمع المنظومه بين قنبله جي بي يو 39
في القطر الصغير ومحرك الصواريخ ام 26
ومحركات الصواريخ امس 26 وتوفر بكثره
نسبيا وتبلغ تكلفه جي بي يو 39 نحو 40000
دولار للقطعه الواحده وهما يجعل القنابل
غير باهظه الثمن ومكوناتها الرئيسيه متاحه
وجاهزه وجيب بيوت 9 و30 التي ستؤدي وظيفه
الراس الانفجاري للقنابل لا جناحان صغيران
مطويه يسمحان لها بالتحرك لاكثر من 100
كلم عند القائها من الطائره يتيح مدى
القنابل محل البحث والذي يبلغ 150 كيلو
مترا يتيح لاوكرانيا ضرب اهداف العسكريه
حيويه كان من الصعب الوصول اليها فضلا عن
مساعدتها في مواصلاتها هجماتها المضاده
لكن من اين ستاتي الاسلحه
الاجابه في وثيقه حصلت عليها رويترز
وتتضمن مقترحا من شركه بوينج الى القياده
العسكريه الامريكيه في اوروبا والتي تشرف
على الاسلحه الموجهه لاوكرانيا اشير
الوثيقه الى ان المكونات الرئيسيه للقنابل
محل البحث ستاتي من المخزون الامريكيه
الحالي الثمن غير الباهظ وتوفر المكونات
من العوامل المساعده على انتاج اسلحه
بحلول مطلع عام 2023 ويمكن تسليم هذه
القنابل في وقت مبكرا من ربيعي العام نفسه
لم تكشف ورشه رسميه حتى اللحظه عن خطه
تزويد اوكرانيا بهذه الاسلحه لكن متحدثا
باسم البنتاجون قال ان الولايات المتحده
وحلفاءها تفكرون في انسب الانظمه التي من
شانها ان تساعد تياف منظومه التسليح
المقترحه التي تتحدث عنها رويترز هي واحده
من ست خطط ينتج تاخيره جديده اوكرانيا
وحلفاء واشنطن في اوروبا الشرقيه كما تقول
مصادر في صناعه الاسلحه الامريكيه حول هذا
الموضوع ينضم الينا من عمان اللواء فايز
الدويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
مرحبا بك لواء فايز هذه الانظمه الجديده
التي يتم البحث بها والحديث عنها كيف من
شانها ان تبدل في موازين القوى وتعطي قوه
اكبر لاوكرانيا في هذه الحرب
المهمه انا اتصل في ربيع 2023 هاي بمعنى
اخر بعد تقريبا اربعه اشهر من الان وهذا
وهذه فتره همم زمنيه ليست همم بالقصيره في
ظل الاحتياجات الان السلاح الرئيسي الذي
يستخدم هي قناه مارس 80 كيلو متر وهمم ادت
دورها بشكل فاعل جدا ولكن يبدو ان
المخزونات الرئيسيه اللي هي مارس بدات
تتاثر وبالتالي حسب منظومه الامداد
الامريكي نظام الامداد الخط الاول والثاني
لا يمكن المساس به والذهاب الى الخط
الثالث همم الان حمار المشكله الرئيسيه
حجم الانتاج السنوي
4600 صاروخ
بعد المصادر ذكرت انه تم ارسال خمسه الاف
يعني اكثر من انتاج عام كامل تم ارساله
وبالتالي بدا البحث عن هذا الموضوع في عام
2019 ليس من الان من اجل عمليه المزاوجه
ما بين المحرك ام همم 7 وما بين الصاروخ
جي بي يو 39 من عام 2019 بدا العمل همم في
التعاون ما بين شركه ايهاب وشركه بوينج
الان اا النقطه المثيره للاهتمام المدى
نتحدث عن مدى 150 كيلو متر فاذا كان
هيمارس قدم هذه الخدمات الكبيره وادى الى
انجاح عمليات القوات الاوكرانيه في خارج
كيف في همم
[موسيقى]
وقدم كثير لهذه المعارك هذا السلاح تقريبا
ضعف المسافه بمعنى اخر انه سيغطي كافه
المنطقه الشرقيه والجنوبيه لا بل يصل الى
داخل الجغرافيا الروسيه
الانظمه انظمه السلاح التي يصل مداها الى
150 كلم اليوم كانت لافته تغريده لمستشار
الرئيس الاوكراني يقول فيها ثلاثه امور
صواريخ باتريوت اف 16
ولا بارد هذا ما يطالب به الجانب
الاوكراني حاليا ما فرص ان يحصل على كل
ذلك
حتى هذه اللحظه حتى هذه اللحظه التي يتحدث
فيها هناك تحدث امريكي
قدم عرضا بديلا صواريخ حكم محسن صواريخ
حكم
وصواريخ
الامريكيه حصلت عليها اثناء فتره تفكك
الاتحاد السوفيتي فاعتبر ان صواريخ
الهجريه الاف 16 حتى هذه اللحظه تعتبر خط
احمر دبابه اليو بارك او ابرامز كذلك تقع
ضمن الخط الاحمر هو في هذا الفيديو مع مش
طلبوا من التوانيا دبابات وغير ذلك لكن
يبدو انها لا تزال تعتبر اسلحه هجوميه وهي
مصممه للادوار الهجوميه وليست للادوار
الدفاعي وبالتالي
هذا الامر يعتبر نقطه فارغه وبالتالي همم
تعتبر روسيا دخول مباشر في المواجهه
العسكريه باختصار شديد لواء فايز انظمه
راجمات صواريخ من فرنسا جرى تسليمها الى
اوكرانيا كيف ايضا من شانها ان تؤثر على
مسار المعارك
يعني تم
ارسال من فرنسا ومن المانيا ليس يعني مارس
2 وام تو 7 ودفاع جوي كروتال هذه ولكنها
بكميات محدوده جدا يعني الان همم عندما
يتم ارسال ثلاث مدافع من المانيا ماذا
ستقدم يعني الان هذه الحرب كما يقال اكله
الاخضر واليابس وبالتالي لاحظ المساعدات
الامريكيه ان تحدث عن خمسه الاف صاروخ همم
مارس الان عندما يتم تزويدهم بثلاثه مدافع
هاوزر من هنا او براجمتي صاروخ من هناك طب
يعني يبقى مساعده رمزيه اكثر منها مساعده
حقيقيه لقلب موازين المعركه اشكرك جزيل
الشكر من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي
مشاهدينا وصلنا الى منتصف الليل بتوقيت
مكه المكرمه وهذا موعدنا مع موجز لاهم
الانباء قبل الانتقال الى الجوله الرياضيه
يوميات المونديال جددت القوات التركيه قصف
مواقع ما تعرف بقوه سوريا ديمقراطيه شمال
شرقي سوريا وافاد مصدر رسمي تركي للجزيره
ان انقر ابلغت الجانب الروسي عدم قبولها
لانتشار الشكلي لقوات النظام السوري في
مناطق قوات سوريا ديموقراطيه اضاف المصدر
ذاته انا تركيا دعت لضروره حللي ما يعرف
بقوه سوريا ديمقراطيه او اخراجها من مناطق
النفوذ الروسيه
من جانبها اكد المندوب التركي ولد الامم
المتحده ان الحديث عن تاثير العمليه
العسكريه التركيه سلبا على الحرب على
تنظيم الدوله غير واقعي
كشف المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
باتريك
ريدر عن تقليص عدد الدوريات الامريكيه
الشماليه سوريا بالتزامن مع تقليص قوات ما
تعرف بسوريا الديمقراطيه دورياتها وقال
المتحدث ان الاتصالات مستمره مع الجانب
التركي بشان التصعيد شماليه سوري سوريا
وفي مجلس الامن الدولي حضر المبعوث الدولي
الى سوريا جير بدرسن من ان تصاعد القتال
قد يعرض الاستقرار الاقليمي للخطر
قال حلف الناتو انه عزز وجوده في جزئه
الشرق بثمن مجموعات قتاليه اضاف الحلف ان
افراد هذه المجموعات من جنسيات مختلفه وهم
مستعدون للقتال ووجودهم يوضح ان الهجوم
على حليفا واحد هو هجوم على الجميع
قال نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي ديميتري
ميتفيديف انه في حال زود حلف الناتو
اوكرانيا بانظمه بيتريوت فاستصبح تلك
الانظمه هدفا مشروعا للقوات الروسيه من
جهتها قال البنتاجون انه لا توجد لديه خطط
لارسال بطاريات بيتريوت الى اوكرانيا رجوء
ذلك ردا على تصريح من الامين العام لحلف
الناتو ان اعضاء الحلف يبحثون تسليما
اوكرانيا منظومه الدفاع بيتريوت المضادات
للصواريخ
نقلت وكاله رويترز ان الحزب الشيوعيه
الصيني اكد ضروره قمعي ما وصفه بعمليات
تسلل وتخريب من قبل القوى المعاديه وفقا
للقانون وفادت مراسله الجزيره بان
الاحتجاجات الشعبيه المطارده برفع
الاغلاقات في مختلف المدن الصينيه توقفت
تعزيزات امنيه مشدده في العاصمه بيجين وفي
شنغهاي
وصلنا الى نهايه الحصاد شكرا لمتابعتكم
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]